♪♪
>> Greg: TODAY WE WOKE UP TO
BREAKING NEWS.
OBAMA ISN'T WOKE AT ALL.
>> THIS IDEA OF PURITY AND NEVER
COMPROMISED AND YOU'RE ALWAYS
POLITICALLY WOKE AND ALL THAT
STUFF, YOU SHOULD GET OVER THAT
QUICKLY.
THE WORLD IS MESSY.
THEY'RE AMBIGUITIES.
PEOPLE THAT DO REALLY GOOD STUFF
HAVE FLAWS.
LIKE IF I TWEET OR HASHTAG ABOUT
HOW YOU DIDN'T DO SOMETHING
RIGHT OR USE THE WRONG VERB OR
THEN, I CAN SIT BACK AND FEEL
GOOD ABOUT MYSELF.
YOU SEE HOW WOKE I WAS?
I CALLED YOU OUT.
YOU KNOW?
THAT'S NOT -- THAT'S NOT
ACTIVISM.
THAT'S NOT BRINGING ABOUT
CHANGE.
>> Greg: WAIT.
YOU'RE TELLING ME THAT RUINING
PEOPLE BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT AS
POLITICALLY PURE AS YOU ARE IS
WRONG?
YOU MEAN YOU, BARACK OBAMA
AGREES EVERYTHING THAT ADAM
CAROLLA AND ALL THOSE OTHERS
HAVE BEEN SAYING ALL ALONG?
HOORAY.
HOW IS DON LEMON TAKING THIS?
WHAT IS "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
EDITORIAL BOARD GOING TO DO?
I HOPE BUZZ FEED AND MEDIA
MATTERS HAVE TAKEN THEIR MEDS.
YEAH.
IT'S GOOD TO HEAR THIS GUY BASH
LEFTIST CANCEL CULTURE.
WISH HE DID IT WHILE HE WAS
PRESIDENT.
MAYBE IT'S NOT HIS FAULT.
HE'S TARDY.
HE DIDN'T REALIZE HOW BAD IT WAS
UNTIL HIS KIDS CAME HOME FROM
COLLEGE AND SAID HOLY CRAP, DAD,
AVOCADOS ARE TOOLS OF THE
PATRIARCHY.
WHEN YOU'RE THE GREATEST
DEMOCRAT ALIVE AND YOUR KIDS
MIGHT ENDS UP JOINING THE YOUNG
REPUBLICANS, YOU HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING.
YOU MIGHT WANT TO CRITICIZE IT
THE WAY THAT OBAMA DID.
THEY SAY YOU NEVER GROW UP UNTIL
YOUR KIDS COME HOME FROM
COLLEGE, WHICH IS WHY I'LL NEVER
GROW UP.
THE PROBLEM WITH WOKE CULTURE,
THE MOMENT YOU CRITICIZE IT,
YOU'RE THE ENEMY.
WILL THIS RED PILLED OBAMA BE